now let me turn to introduce our
speakers today our first speaker is
Peter de marzo
he's a faculty member at the Stanford
Graduate School of Business in addition
to his experience at the Graduate School
of Business peter has taught at the Haas
School of Business and the Keller
Graduate School of Management and was a
visiting scholar at the Hoover
Institution he's a member of the
National Bureau of Economic Research and
past president of the Western finance
Association his research is in the area
of corporate finance assets secure is a
ssin financial contracting and market
regulation recent work has examined
issues of the optin his recent work as
design has examined issues of the
optimal design of securities optimal
compensation mechanisms regulation of
insider trading and broker dealers bank
capital regulation and influence of
information isometrics on corporate
disclosures and investment welcome Peter
thanks first let me thank you everyone
here at the Stanford center for
professional development this great
opportunity to be here and thank you for
hosting this and thanks to all the
participants for for joining in and I
look forward to today's session I was
asked to give a general interest finance
talk today and when you're a finance
professor there is a big occupational
hazard pretty much anybody anywhere will
stop you to ask for investment advice
you know what our interest rates going
to do what do you think of this stock
pick my cousins a doctor has more or
less the same problem although he says
the good thing is whatever vice he gives
90 percent of all ailments go away on
their own and he gets the credit
unfortunately as a finance professor
when things go well people think they're
the geniuses and only blame you when
things go wrong so with that caveat let
me tell you a bit about investing in
financial markets what the data shows
and some important mistakes to avoid
much of what I'm going to say many of
you have heard probably in some form
before but you may not have fully come
to appreciate their implications I'm
going to start I'm going to start with a
picture that you've probably all seen in
some form it's probably the most famous
picture in finance and that's the
historical performance
of different types of investments what
we're going to do is go back in time to
1925 and imagine where our grandparents
or great-grandparents investing on our
behalf and so suppose we had $100 to
invest at that time and we start with
the most conservative investment
Treasury bills we put a hundred dollars
in Treasury bills at that time by 2012
it would have grown to almost it's a
little over 2000 dollars and that seems
impressive until you think about what
happened to prices during that time
let's plot the Consumer Price Index over
the same period and you'll see that
you'd need almost 1300 dollars today to
have the same purchasing power as $100
in 1925 so investing in tea bills would
have increased your purchasing power but
less than doubled it okay let's suppose
instead we invested in corporate bonds
rather than government bonds if we look
at what happened a hundred ollar
investment in corporate bonds over the
period we'll see would have grown to
over $20,000 in other words about ten
times as much as we would have gotten in
government bonds let's take a look and
compare now to stocks if we invest it
has invested $100 in the S&P 500 which
is a portfolio of the 500 largest stocks
in the market that hundred dollar
investment would have grown to about two
hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars
again a more than 10x improvement over
what we had with corporate bonds finally
let's look at an investment in small
stocks one hundred dollars invested in
small stocks back in 1925 would have
grown to over two million dollars today
and again another 10x improvement over
that investment in large stocks so this
picture makes a pretty compelling case
for considering investing in the stock
market but if you look at it closely
you'll see it tells another and perhaps
even more important story well we might
expect these investments to rank in this
way over shorter horizons there's no
guarantee there's a great deal of risk
involved so let's just take a look at a
couple of examples of that let's go back
to imagine we were a stock market
investors in 1929 if you had invested in
the stock market in 1929 that's that
Blucher
that you see here it would have taken
until roughly the end of World War two
before that investment would have turned
out better than just keeping your money
underneath your mattress over that
period so quite a long horizon you would
have to wait to see some benefit from
your investment let's take another a
more recent example if we go to the
stock market in 1999 and again as this
picture shows we expect the stock market
to outperform bonds but if you had
switched to corporate bonds in 1999 that
investment would have come out way ahead
even a decade later than where you are
in the stock market over this period and
it's only very recently in the past year
that we've started to see the stocks
make gains relative to bonds much more
recently one more example to take a look
at a small stocks suppose back in the
early 80s you had seen this graph up
until that point in time and got
convinced that small stocks were a great
investment opportunity if you had
switched to small stocks in the early
1980s you would have been sorely
disappointed with that investment choice
over most of the next 30 years and it's
only very recently that small stocks
have started to come back and make gains
relative to larger stocks so as I said
this picture is really hiding a fair
amount of uncertainty a fair amount of
risk another way to understand that is
to take the same data and presented a
bit differently let me provide you with
a histogram showing the frequency of
different levels of annual returns for
these different types of investments for
example let's look at Treasury bills if
we plot out the histogram for Treasury
bills it looks like this and what you'll
see is that most of the time you earn
between 0 and 5 percent investing in
Treasury bills some of the time between
5 and 10 percent and a few years we were
able to earn between 10 and 15%
investing in Treasury bills that was
back in the early 80s when interest
rates were quite high but overall a very
tight distribution not a lot of
variability in the returns for Treasury
bills if I compare that to corporate
bonds you see a bit more spread out
distribution
some years you actually lost some money
in corporate bonds through defaults or
downgrades other years you might have
made quite a bit more in corporate bonds
compared to Treasuries applying the same
data for stocks we see an even wider
distribution here the annual returns
range between - 50 % - + 50 % and of
course as we probably expect small
stocks are going to show the widest
distribution of all the most volatile of
these 4 investment categories now we can
measure the variability in terms of the
standard deviation of these annual
returns which we refer to in finance as
the assets of volatility so volatility
just another word for standard deviation
of these returns and you can see that we
have the same ranking as we saw on
performance at least volatile being
Treasury bills than corporate bonds then
large stocks and then small stocks now I
can take both of those observations and
put them together in one figure like I
showed here where on the vertical axis
I've plotted the store achill average
return for these different investment
categories and on the horizontal axis
I've plotted their historical volatility
and I've thrown it a couple of other
investments as well put a worldwide
portfolio of stocks together with a
mid-cap stock portfolio just so you can
see how they align as well and what you
can see immediately in this picture is a
trade-off between risk and return and
that's exactly what we should expect
because of their higher volatility for
example to attract investors small
stocks need to offer a higher average
return otherwise investors won't invest
in them another way of saying this is
there's no free lunch in the market if
you want the higher return of stocks
you're going to need to accept the risk
that goes with it you're not getting
something for nothing that high return
is a reward for your willingness to take
to take risk indeed if we draw a line in
this picture through Treasury bills and
the overall market portfolio of the
sp500 which we'll think of as a proxy
for the for the broader market we get
what is called the security market line
and this represents the risk and return
opportunities that are available to
investors by investing in the stock
market you
choose where you want to be on this line
based upon your risk tolerance
you can either invest more in the stock
market or more in Treasuries to locate
somewhat lower down on the line or
somewhat higher up and even leverage
your position the stock market if you
want to if you're willing to take a lot
of risk but hope for an even higher
expected return now that's the basically
the menu that's available to you as an
investor and what I want to point out is
that it's really hard to get above this
line
very few investment opportunities offer
sustained returns in the region up here
above the line every now and then an
investment opportunity will appear that
does seem to offer very high returns
with very low risk but most often it
turns out to be an illusion the point I
plotted here is actually made offs
reported returns and we know what
happened there right it was really just
a Ponzi scheme and so in general it's
very hard to find investment
opportunities that are consistently
above this line now while it's really
hard to get above this line it's very
easy to wind up below it if I plot
individual stock and investment
portfolios you'll find something like
this so lots of individual investors and
portfolio strategies end up well below
the security market line that I plotted
in other words individuals off
individual investors are often taking
excessive risk or sacrificing return by
making some basic errors and by doing so
we'll end up well below that security
market line that I just showed you and
what I want to talk about today is some
of the errors that people make and how
to avoid them how do we end up below
this line and how do we avoid doing that
in particular what we'll see is that
individuals often end up taking
excessive risk by holding concentrated
portfolios and trying to engage in
market timing they'll end up sacrificing
return by paying too much in fees and
trading costs again trying to market
time and also exposing themselves to
adverse selection and I want to give you
an insight into into each of those so
that you can understand
how those errors can creep into your
portfolio okay so let's talk a little
bit about how individuals investor
behaved and what are some of the common
mistakes that they make well the first
one is very basic when we look at the
portfolio's of small investors what we
tend to find is that they're very under
diversified many just hold one or two
stocks in their portfolio often it's the
same stock of the company that they're
working for I sometimes refer this as
the Enron problem in an allusion to the
energy trading company that collapsed
back around 2000 many of their employees
had most of their retirement savings in
company stock and so what happened was
they lost their jobs and their
retirement savings at the same time so
in some sense
being doubly under versified now it
turns out that you can cut your risk by
more than half without sacrificing
returns simply by trying to spread your
investments out diversifying to
different industries different locales
etc spraying those investments around
it's not too hard to get rid of more
than half of the risk that you would
take investing in the stock market so
that's one obvious implication I'm sure
one that you've heard before the other
thing I want to mention is something we
see in the pattern in the way
individuals trade when investors buy
stocks what we notice is that they tend
to sell the stocks quickly when they go
up whereas they hold on to them when
they fall now there are a couple of
interesting things about that first of
all it tends to be a tax inefficient
strategy for tax purposes typically what
you'd like to do is defer realizing your
gains that you can delay paying taxes on
your gains and accelerate the
realization of your losses so you can
get tax credits for any losses that
you've incurred and so it doesn't make
sense from a tax standpoint but it could
make sense if investors know something
if you know the stocks they sell when
they've gone up have finished their run
their upward run and they're holding
onto stocks that have fallen because
they expect them to turn around well if
we look at the actual data this is what
you find and this is from a study by
Oh Dean and Barber what they find is
that if we look at the stocks that
investors sold and looked at how they
performed over the rest of the year
after investors sold them compared to
the overall market those stocks that
investors sold tended to continue going
up relative to the market
in other words investors seem to be
selling the winners too quickly
and on the downside if we look at the
losers that investors are holding in
their portfolio again relative to the
market over the remainder of the year
those stocks seem to continue to
underperform the market and so they're
hanging on to losers too long and so we
see this asymmetry and investor behavior
is taxed and efficient but even more
importantly it's costing them in terms
of the returns telling the winners too
quickly holding on to the losers longer
than they should the other thing that we
see when we look at individual traders
is that individuals tend to trade a lot
especially men especially single men why
well you know most things in life you
add value by doing something and so
presumably traders have the same feeling
the annual turnover numbers by the way
here represent the fraction of shares
and their portfolio traded in a single
year now as I said you know people feel
like you need to do something in order
to add value to their portfolio but guys
you should only do something if you know
something and if we look at performance
it actually doesn't look so great so
sorry to show you this but in fact just
compared to holding a basic market index
fund most those individual investors are
underperforming on average and single
men doing worst of all now that picture
doesn't tell the whole story because I
haven't yet added in fees that they have
to pay trading commissions and the like
when I add in fees here's the picture
that you see once I've included in those
transactions costs so a lot of trading
activity but at least on average it's
not working out so well for these
individual investors and that's a
general pattern that you tend to see if
I look more generally at investors
and the frequency of their trade and the
amount of turnover in their portfolios
what you find is that performance
average performance tends to decrease
with the amount of perform with the
amount of turnover the more actively
they're trading
they're doing worse partly because of
exactly those fees and trading costs
that they have to pay this bracket
v quanta quintile here these are those
single men I was talking about you know
studies have looked at this group more
closely and found that these folks tend
to you know be much more likely at doing
other risky and impulsive things get
more speeding tickets and so forth than
other folks on average so there seems to
be some sensation-seeking
behavior going on there as well so
hopefully they're enjoying doing all
that trading their portfolios aren't
necessarily benefiting from it okay let
me tell you some other things obviously
we've shown it doesn't pay to trade
randomly but you know suppose you do
your homework you read The Wall Street
Journal every day you just trade when
you learn some good or bad news about a
company well like that old adage you
know buy the rumor sell the news by the
time the news comes out it's the price
is already adjusted and there are no
more gains to be had let's take just a
quick look at that if we look at good
news that's announced in the Wall Street
Journal for individual companies days
zero here is the day that the
announcement appears in The Wall Street
Journal and what you'll see is that you
know once we're at that point if you
were to buy the stock at that point in
time there's really not much upward
movement that you should expect in the
stock price going forward that it's
already that the good news has already
been incorporated in the stock price by
the time it's in the newspaper if we
look at bad news we see a very similar
phenomena again by the time that bad
news is out there it's again already
incorporating the stock price we're not
going to make any money by selling the
stock at that point in time and so again
just be worried of trading on public
information the evidence shows that most
of there are many gains to be had from
doing so okay so the
the other problem with active trading in
addition to just the transactions cost
and tax consequences is that you're
exposing yourself to what we refer to as
adverse selection and the point is that
whenever you buy you're feeling someone
else's sell order and only one of you
can be beating the market so while you
may think you're picking stocks it's
potentially more likely that you're the
one being picked off by a more savvy
investor you know as a recent scandal
just that kind of reminds us of this
happened with Goldman Sachs a trader
there for breach a to RA is sometimes
were just fabulous fab was selling
mortgage Studios to the banks and had
convinced the banks that they were the
ones picking the mortgage mortgages that
were going into their portfolio when
actually the mortgages that they were
getting had been picked had been
handpicked by famous short seller John
Paulson on the other side who made about
over a billion dollars on those on those
trades and when that was revealed
Goldman Sachs
suffered in terms of their reputation
and so forth with their customers but
the general point is a good one whenever
you're out there trading there's someone
who's likely to be someone informed
who's trading on the other side and
you've got to decide are you the one
smarter than average or are they really
trading against you and picking you off
in the process let me give you a sort of
a concrete example of this adverse
selection problem in the context of IPOs
you may be aware that most IPOs tend to
go up on the first day in fact if you
look historically over time you'll see
it's a pretty consistent pattern that
IPOs go on average about 15% the first
day there's an upward jump in the stock
price when they first start trading and
that might suggest that we can make a
lot of money simply by investing $10,000
in every IPO that comes out if we look
at you know roughly 100 IPOs per year if
we made $1,500 in each one that's about
$150,000 per year that we could make if
we follow the strategy and could enjoy
those 15% returns well not so fast it is
true that
I chose tend to go up on average by 15%
but first of all they don't always go up
so if you look at it some of them go up
by more than 15% but some actually fall
in value
anybody remember Facebook right and
Facebook did not go up the first day and
actually had a decline in value the
first day and so while the average
return is 15% there's actually some
variability around that so let's just
take kind of a an approximate
distribution here saying about 80% of
the time they go up and they go up on
average of about 20% and about 20% of
the time those IPOs fall on the first
day and they go down on average of about
5% now that still leads us to a 15%
average return if we just do the math
here multiplying each row and then
combining them you get about a 15%
average return so why can't we make
money doing this well the problem is if
we look at the allocation that you're
going to get in the IPO you're not going
to be able to invest $10,000 in every
IPO why is that well because the very
successful IPOs tend to be
oversubscribed and while you might put
in an order for $10,000 at $10,000 worth
of the stock your broker may only be
able to deliver a much smaller amount
say $500 worth is a stock it's not
unusual for very popular IPOs to be 20
times oversubscribed that is there's 20
times the demand for the number of
shares they actually have outstanding
and so you're going to get to only some
fraction of the amount they requested on
the other hand the less popular IPO is
the one where the price is likely to
fall your broker is likely to come back
and say you know what I was able to fill
most of your order I got you eight
thousand dollars worth of that IPO now
of course we don't know which you're
going to be the most popular ones
upfront and so if we now do the math and
look at the allocation we actually get
multiplying again each row and adding up
we'll see that we're not actually making
any profit in this situation because
we're experiences out of our selection
we're getting much less of the very
successful IPOs and a much bigger aleck
allocation of the less successful ones
and the more informed traders basically
taking that profit not leaving anything
left for us so again sort of this even
though we know that the average returns
look good just a naive investment here
would not pay off one last piece of
evidence I'll show you some of you may
be familiar with the show Mad Money and
there's a recent study looked at Mad
Money recommendations and again found
kind of a similar pattern that is when
they looked at Mad Money recommendations
for stocks where there was news what
they found was that news was already
incorporated into the stock price and
there were no real further gains to be
had if you traded on that Mad Money
recommendation on the other hand if we
looked at stocks for which there was no
news and Mad Money was making kind of an
independent recommendation independent
of any news announcement first of all
these tended to be smaller stocks but
what you found is that people bought
into those stocks and they tended to be
over - Ischl e and that's over the next
several weeks stock tended to fall and
while there was overall a persistent
positive uptick in the stock price
getting in with the crowd sort of
hurting with a bunch of investors all
trying to get in meant you might be over
paying up front and actually losing a
few percentage points over the next few
weeks on average as some of that hype
dissipated okay so we've talked a lot
about some of the traps that individual
investors fall into what about
professional investors and you know
mutual fund managers what does
performance look like there well let's
take a look at that next and here's
here's an interesting picture if you
look at mutual fund performance what
you'll find for average mutual fund
performance if we look at actively
managed funds is that they - tend to
underperform just a broader market index
portfolio okay on average by about half
a percent per year over all categories
we also find that the under performance
is closely related with the fund fees
that is the higher the fees the Fund
charge the worse your performance so in
some sense you know the reverse of you
get what you pay for
here are paying higher fees only got you
worse performance and that's an
interesting observation I think many
investors aren't aware of that
you know it's simply investing in a
mutual fund at random or an average
mutual fund is likely to be worse than
investing in in a simple market index
now it doesn't mean it's impossible to
read the market there could be some
funds that do beat the market but it
does suggest that doing so is either
likely to be luck or otherwise based on
something unsustainable or perhaps
involve hidden risk or finally be
something you know based on something
that's that's hard to copy that is a
fund manager we need to have access to
you know information that others don't
have or some unique investment
opportunities have special trading
efficiencies that they can exploit or
some unique talent in interpreting the
data now of course this is what we hope
for is something in this last category
where it's really something sustainable
but the real question is if the manager
does have some unique talent like that
why would the fund manager give it away
why would they give that benefit to
their investors rather than charging for
through their fees and in fact that's
what we seem to find even those managers
who do have talent and are able to beat
the market are charging more in fees
than the amount by which they they
outperform let me show you another
picture that kind of highlights this if
we look at institutional fund managers
these are fund managers who manage stock
investments for pension funds endowments
etc and if we look at past performance
before they got hired say by the pension
fund it's hiring them their past
performance does show them beating the
market on average by about three percent
per year which is significant given that
the average institutional fund manager
only beats the market by about sixty
basis points per year that's that
average line I have in there as well
and so this is exactly what you'd expect
you know pension funds or hiring
managers who are outperforming who look
great relative to the average so what do
you think happens after they get hired
if we look at the data after they get
hired well if we look at that data what
you see is this picture
in other words this is what we call
regression to the mean their performance
after being hired looks a lot like that
average performance we don't see a
persistence of the superior performance
we shall be we saw beforehand which
suggests one of two things both probably
factors one is that that that past
performance was in large part luck and
unlikely to be repeated and number two
even if there was some component of
skill these fund managers now been hired
to manage a much larger portfolio than
they were managing before and it's
difficult to sustain the same relative
gains on a much larger portfolio now you
will note that they still are an average
though beating the market by about 50 to
75 basis points per year
but the typical institutional fees are
about 50 basis points per year so this
amount by which they're beating the
market more or less is in line with the
fees that they're charging suggesting
very little of that benefit is going to
the ultimate investors okay um let me
give you I've talked a lot about why you
know it's hard to make money actively
investing in the market trying to pick
stocks and time the market let me give
you a very simple logic for why passive
investing at least on average must
always win relative to active investing
okay if you think about the market and
let's segregate into two types passive
investors who simply all hold the market
index and active investors who are
picking stocks going in and out of the
market trying to time the market if we
look at the passive investor obviously
they're just earning the market index
return what about the active investor
what are they
earning on average that pool of
investors well of course if we look at
the overall market which includes both
passive and active investors what's the
average return in the overall market
well that has to be the market index
return again the average of the entire
market must but just be the market index
and so if these if we look at this
equation here for these two to average
out to the market in
it must be that on average active
investors are also earning the market
index return except that they're paying
trading costs they're paying for tax and
efficiencies because of the high
turnover in their portfolio and as a
result are going to on average
underperform between you know two to
five percent relative to the overall
market and that's just a simple math
that there's no way to avoid so on
average the pool of immaculate active
investors must be under performing a
simple index fund or passive strategy
and the only way that some investors
might be beating the market is that
other investors are in there in that
active pool who are willing to lose to
the market okay and so you just want to
make sure you are not one of those
investors who's basically providing the
opportunity for some of those other
attractive investors to win out okay let
me look at one last phenomena which is
an interesting one so here we've talked
a lot about the average fund manager the
average institutional fund manager and
so forth
can we do better can we kind of look at
past performance and try to find out who
is it that's got hot hands who's doing
well in the market now who should I put
my money with is there a way to kind of
identify the winners and invest with
them and in particular in particular can
we use past performance to try to pick
winning funds so let me just tell you a
couple of stories along along these
lines and and tell you what the evidence
shows so first of all let's take a look
at the following so investment
newsletters investment newsletters often
provide advice on which stocks to invest
in and so forth there was a study that
was done that looked at a decade of
performance so 1992 2000 and what the
study did was the following each year we
looked at which was the best performing
investment newsletter from the prior
year okay so which investment letter had
had the most outstanding returns and
then we're going to follow that
newsletters recommendations in the
coming year
okay so we're going to do that each year
or it's an entire in decade find the
best-performing from the prior year and
then invest in that newsletter in the
coming year let's see what happens if we
follow that strategy now if you invested
in the S&P 500 over this decade over the
90s a $100,000 investment would have
grown to about $500,000 it was a great
decade for the stock market as we all
know if you had followed the
best-performing newsletter strategy
$100,000 investment would have grown to
$70,000 okay not a very good performance
indeed and in some sense if we step back
and think about it
we probably shouldn't be all that
surprised so why do I say that well if
you think about what we're selecting on
when we're finding the highest return
investment newsletter from the prior
year what's the main thing we'll
probably sell out into selecting on we
might be selecting on skill but we're
most likely selecting on risk right how
do you get to be an outlier well you did
something really risky and you got lucky
and so we're probably selecting on
newsletters who invested in very risky
portfolios and if we follow those
newsletters in the coming year and they
take similar risk there's no reason to
expect that their luck is going to go
the same in the coming year as it did in
the prior year so that's a really
important observation that whenever
you're looking at past performance if
you're just looking at absolute returns
you're in some sense selecting on risk
and probably selecting on risk much more
than you're selecting on skill it
reminds me of a story of my niece was
taking an economics class in middle
school and they were doing a stock
market segment and each the idea was
each student was supposed to pick a
portfolio and at the end of the month
they would see whose portfolio did the
best and whoever did the best was going
to win a prize I forget what it was was
tickets to some local concert that was
going to be happening or something like
that and she was very interested in this
and really wanted to win this prize and
so she came to me for advice and so you
know against my better judgment I
thought okay let me let me see if I can
help her here
and so I asked her well there's a prize
if you win you know what happens if you
lose and she said well there's no
there's no penalty if you lose you know
it's just kind of a fun thing for the
winner you get these concert tickets and
so forth and so I said well if your only
goal is to try and win you know the best
strategy is let's find some really
really risky penny stocks and we're
going to leverage the heck out of your
portfolio and you know with basically
50-50 chance you're going to get lucky
and you're going to have astronomical
returns and another 50% chance you're
getting unlucky and lose everything but
you don't care about how much you lose
and so it took her a while to to get
this but in the end she sort of got the
logic of I thought this was a great idea
and so we found some stocks we leveraged
it up and all looks good until a week
later she came home from school with a
note from the teacher and tears and
apparently the teacher was upset because
she had demoralized the rest of the
class because her portfolio was doing so
well no one else felt like they could
catch up and it kind of ruined the
spirit of the whole exercise and so we
couldn't win anyway in that sense so
it's just something to keep in mind
again when we're look just looking at
Absolute performance fund managers have
an incentive to take extra risk just to
look good and get that attention but you
don't want to be picking your funds
based on risk so let me tell you
something another more sensible
selection strategy that we might follow
all right and you know if we look at
Forbes and Morningstar lots of services
provide a ranking of mutual funds where
they don't just look at Absolute
performance where they try to look at an
assessment of risk in the past and based
upon both return and risk try to say
well who's delivered good performance
given the level of risk that they were
taking and so for example force has an
honor roll of outstanding mutual funds
and there are other similar you know
Morningstar has their star categories
and so forth where they try to rank
mutual funds on this basis doing
something much more sensible trying to
look at risk and return this is
obviously a much better thing to do we
want to weight in both risk and return
in our recommendations but how does that
work out what's the persistence there
well there was a study a famous study
looked at these honor roll funds and
said what if we invest each year in
those honor roll funds for 25 years so
each year looking at those that are most
highly ranked in the honor roll and then
follow those funds in the coming year if
we did that for a 25 year period our
annual returns over the period of study
would have been about thirteen point six
percent that's it that's a quite a nice
return now it's a bit of an over
estimate because I'm not counting sales
loads and fees in here and as you move
from one mutual fund to another you may
have had to pay some fees and would have
had tax consequences and so forth if we
look at the overall market over the same
twenty five year period you would have
found in the stock market about a
fourteen point three percent return just
investing in the sp500 index so again
what you see is while that ranking is
much more sensible there's still not a
lot of persistence and not enough to
overcome the fees and other charges that
you pay in these mutual funds it's very
hard to predict the winners let me just
give you one last a very specific story
on this point and this is the story of
Bill Miller's Legg Mason value trust
mutual fund and Bill Bill Miller was a
very famous and investment circles and
let me tell you the story of why his fun
started in the mid-1980s in in early 90s
really started to do well with the fund
at about 700 million unasked in assets
under management early 90s and started
to outperform the market and each year
from 90 1990 through 1998-99 Bill Miller
beat the overall market so every year
has superior returns to the overall
market in 1998 Morningstar named to
manager of the year in 1999 Morningstar
name - manager of this decade and Bill
Miller start to become very famous as
you know the mutual fund out there
mutual fund manager out there with
persistent performance can persistently
be in the market was on to something
that was real and that was going to
continue to deliver value
and that was true that continued from
from 2000 through 2005 even though the
overall market didn't do so great with
the dot-com bust through that period
Miller continued to beat the market
every year even when it went down he
went down buy less of the market when it
went up he went up by more than the
market and so in and - at the end of
2005 fortunate manager named him the
greatest manager of our time and by 2007
Bill Miller had over 28 billion in
assets under management okay now in 2006
his lucky streak broke he didn't quite
beat the market in 2006 but performance
still looks good up in through mid 2007
and I said attracting a lot of investor
attention 28 billion under management
what happened to those investors who
jumped in at that point well the fun did
not do very well in the market crash and
this is what happened during the market
crash the overall market down about 50%
Legg Mason value trust down about 70%
during this period basically giving back
all the gains that had been earned over
that 15-year period through the crash
and a couple of years later bill miller
eventually retired and retired at the
end of his career with a slight positive
performance average performance over the
sp500 if we look over his entire career
beating the market by a little bit but
his investors on average did not fare so
well why is that well if you remember
back here I said the fund had about 700
million dollars under management ie
there weren't that many investors who
got to experience the bulk of this
run-up where we were beating the market
where the fund was being a market but we
had 28 billion in assets under
management here before the fall and so a
lot more investors participated in the
fall then participated in run-up and so
if you look at the average investor
performance of investors who invested in
this fund they were actually well below
the market over this period and again
that's that market timing aspect that I
mentioned to you unless you're in it all
the time
your average performance might look much
worse than the average performance of
the fund or the investment itself okay
so that's an important lesson from the
market and again what the evidence seems
to show is that overall there's very
little predictability on the upside
there's very little ability to predict
which funds which managers are going to
do well going forward there is however
some persistence in a mutual fund
returns however it's not the kind that's
very helpful in particular the
persistence we do see is that the very
first funds those in the bottom quartile
tend to stay bad and the reason is that
typically that really bottom performance
is based upon very high trading fees
very high commissions and the like and
those things persist and soar likely to
keep them in the bottom quartile going
forward so hard to pick the winners but
don't get trapped in the losers pay
attention to those fees stay with a very
low cost fund that's not trying to do
anything very sophisticated and you're
likely to be better off okay this is a
final thoughts on all this key things to
remember first we can't all be above
average for one investor to beat the
market another must lose so I think a
useful visual to have in your mind
whenever you're thinking of picking
stocks or trying to time the market is
you know think about Warren Buffett
sitting on the other side with his
friendly Nebraska smile happily taking
your trades on the other side and so you
know you've got to be confident that
you're better than the average smart
investor out there who's on the other
side of your trades in order for you to
think that you can make money by doing
that in general it pays to be passive by
holding that market index fund you're
going to guarantee that you're on that
security market line okay that security
market line is a good place to be as I
said it's very hard to be above that and
it's really easy to fall below that
whenever you deviate
only be active when either you have good
reason to be different so you know you
might have very different portfolio
needs and other investors your job is
heavily invested in the tech sector and
so you might want to have a portfolio
that's less invested in a tech sector to
diversify from that in terms of the
timing of your investment
you know you should be investing on a
regular basis and only withdrawing funds
when you need them to make down payment
on a house to pay for college education
etc don't be trying to end on the market
in response to you know fears of a crash
or things like that you're more likely
to be crowding with the herd and
actually sacrificing returns if you do
so or if you're a very good reason to
think you're above average you know
you're an industry expert in a
particular topic well if you do think
you've got some some insight into a
particular industry a particular firm
the others don't have that might be a
good reason to trade but just remember
you're you're playing poker with the
pros when you do that and so you've got
to be really confident to do so
and finally beware of fees as I
mentioned active managers often take
more than they add their fees when
you're trading on your own and just be
careful even 1% per year in either
trading fees or commissions or payments
to active managers 1% per year doesn't
sound like a lot but over your career
that's going to add up to more than a
third of your retirement savings all
right so I like to say you know you're
really funding three people's retirement
right yourself your spouse and your
broker if you're doing a lot of trading
and so that's something that you just
want to be careful of so with that let
me just wrap it up and mention that
these ideas and more are in in a book
that you can find where a lot of this
material is drawn from and let me turn
it back over to the folks here at the
Stanford center for professional
development hello Peter everyone thank
you Peter for that wonderful
presentation
I'd like to introduce Paul marca the
executive director of Stanford center
for professional development he is
responsible for collaborating with
Stanford faculty industry experts and
corporate partners to develop the
curriculum of graduate degrees graduate
and professional certificates and
courses and contract training for one of
the largest universities continuing
education organizations and distance
education networks so Paul will walk us
through some of the some of the
offerings that we have available for you
thank you very much Roni and thank you
Peter
I had the
meaning Peter justice last year when
professor and president John Hennessy
asked us both to serve on the
presidential Advisory Committee on
technology and higher higher education
here at Stanford University much of this
was to discuss this massively open and
online courses and certainly we believe
that that may be a significant change
it's been great to talk with Peter about
this but more importantly I think School
of Engineering and the Graduate School
of Business have partnered together to
create an online certificate program the
Stanford innovation and online Stanford
innovation and entrepreneurship
certificate many of the fundamental
market fundamentals that Peter shared
with you today will certainly lead to
tools and techniques and perspectives
that Peter will share actually in just a
few moments regarding the course that
he's going to be teaching where
investors can think about tools and
techniques and perspectives as startups
emerge and how to really think about
those things the program that we are
excited to be delivering this
certificate program as I mentioned is
being led by Professor hayagriva huggy
Rao at the Graduate School of Business
as well as Professor Bob Sutton and
management science and engineering as
part of the School of Engineering a
department here and we've been excited
to gather a faculty from across the
campus leverage some of the best
insights and create this program which
will include not only exercises in
assignments great lectures from our
faculty but also some ta feedback where
you can test your mettle and get some
improved insights as you're moving
forward with that venture journey what I
wanted to do by the way we remind you
that questions will are still coming in
thank you for those there are some
general market questions there are also
some specific questions for Peter on
some perspectives on on how innovators I
need to think about financing so we may
be able to get to some of those I know
there was some interest in that
certainly the course that Peters going
to share maybe give us a quick
perspective on this is titled financing
innovation valuing projects and firms
and it'll be launched in September
and Peter maybe I can turn back to you
for just a few minutes to talk about
some of the perspectives in the course
but maybe also answer some of the
questions that are coming in about how
you think about this relatively risky
perhaps of startup notion and what
models we might use to to think about
entrepreneurship and new ventures great
well thanks Paul and it's a delight to
get to work with you and also to be
working with this online program and I'm
very excited about this new course what
we've been talking about today is real
focus on stock market investing but in
the course we're going to focus on real
projects and how should you or your firm
decide whether to invest in a new
product develop a new technology or make
an acquisition and what we're going to
do in that course has really developed a
skill to create a full financial model
for an investment project and use it
both to both make the case to get our
project funded whether that's internally
or externally and then use it to analyze
our investment and optimize the value
that we're creating in that investment
opportunity so we're gonna be looking at
basically internal capital markets in
the firm how do you sell your project
internally and try to get it funded how
do public companies and startups raise
capital from outside investors and how
is their stock value in the market so a
lot of the lessons that we talked about
today in terms of a general perspective
of investors in the stock market is
going to be relevant there as we try to
think about well how do we stand out how
do we attract that scarce investment
capital of those investors who are
looking to make to make a new investment
we're not going to assume any background
in finance in the course but by the end
of this course you're gonna have the
skills to build your own financial model
in Excel and to evaluate your project or
firms I hope you're gonna you'll join me
with that and I think it'll be
interesting for those of you who have an
interest and want to really understand
how to apply the tools of finance to
thinking about investments in real
projects and in in real companies let me
turn to a couple of the questions that
we've had and in a particular company be
asking you know so bottom line what is
the recommendation and what are some
good things that I should be holding in
my portfolio
and first yes you might you might have
gotten that a key take away a key take
away that we found if the evidence shows
repeatedly is that for you know for non
professional investors if this is not
your main activity that by and large the
very best thing you can do is to hold a
broadly diversified low-cost index fund
so something like a total stock market
index fund it has very low fees Vanguard
other firms provide these through a
mutual funds their ETFs that provide the
same thing together with a similar
broadly diversified bond fund and
perhaps international fund that those
together should really form the core of
your portfolio and not by doing so
you're going to outperform over time
I'll perform almost every other
alternative out there but by doing that
mutual funds are a great choice if you
have to trade frequently because you're
investing small bits over time or may
need to take your money in and out
because you can often trade without any
trading cost whatsoever
ETS are great for long horizon investors
because you get to control really when
you're gonna realize the gains for tax
purposes and so forth and so that could
be a better strategy for very long
horizon but those are just some of the
general recommendations and the point is
it's really difficult to do that it's
difficult even for professional but to
beat that it's difficult for
professional fund managers to beat that
and certainly if this is not your main
activity and your main air of expertise
it's going to be very very hard for you
to beat that on your own
some folks asked if you you know if
you're interested in taking more risk
what do you recommend and I would say if
you're interested in taking more risk in
average a couple things you can do one
certainly is you'll have a larger
portion of your portfolio invested in
the stock market if you're comfortable
with that and so the amount you invest
is a good way to calibrate the risk that
you're taking and in addition you might
be willing to with a small part of your
portfolio take some active bets in
things where you think you have some
some primary expertise but again that
shouldn't be the major part of your
portfolio you don't want to sacrifice
the big benefits of it
certification so keep the bulk of your
portfolio highly diversified you can
take a smaller portion and do some
active bets with it another question was
you know can an investment advisor be
worth it and I would say yes an
investment advisor can be worth it
the ones who are worth it are those who
are gonna steer you away from making the
mistakes that we talked about today who
are going to prevent you from jumping on
your emotions and trading on hype going
in and out of the market too frequently
getting you to stay the course and stick
to a long term investment strategy and
stay with a highly diversified portfolio
that's really the best things that an
investment advisor can generally do for
you and those things if you're not
disciplined enough to do them on your
own can well be worth the fees that they
charge for actual stock making advice
though the evidence is I hate to say it
but those investment advisors aren't
really making up for their fees in terms
of their stock picking advice so those
are again just some general takeaways to
be aware of I know we're running short
on time so let me let me stop here